you mentioned gato's a completeness
theorem uh can you can you talk a little
bit about it what is it as you
understand it did it break mathematics
maybe another question is what are the
limits of mathematics what is
mathematics from the perspective of
getting us to completeness theorem well
yes
how much time do you have
but we've talked about time previously
so the time is an illusion right so we
agreed to see it
um was a great uh Austrian mathematician
and logician
he moved to the United States before
second world war and worked at The
Institute for advanced study in
Princeton where he was a colleague of
Einstein and other great scientists for
Neumann Hermann Weil and so on but you
know one one interesting
quote that I like in this regard is that
Einstein said that at some point he said
that the only reason he came to the
Institute was that he would have the
privilege of walking back home with
gyodo in the evening so in other words
Einstein thought that the girl was the
smart one okay so
um so he um his most important
contribution
was his two
incompleteness ethereums the first
incompleteness theorem and the second
incompleteness theorem
and um
what is this about it's really about
limitation inherent limitations of
mathematical reasoning
but my way of producing mathematical
theorems the way we do it so to set the
stage
how do we actually do mathematics what
is so you know we know that we discussed
that
say physics is based on mathematics and
you could say chemistry is based on
physics biology based on chemistry okay
so it comes to mathematics what is
mathematics based on
well mathematics is based on axioms
so any
field of mathematics is can be can be
presented as what is called the formal
system
and at the core of the formal system is
a system of axioms or postulas these are
the statements
which are taken for granted
given without proof without proof an
example would be so that one of the very
first promo systems was the system was
euclidean geometry developed by Euclid
in his famous book elements about 2200
years ago
and it's about it's well it's a subject
Familia from from school because we
studied
but what it's really about is about the
geometry of the plane and the plane by
plane I mean just the stable top
extended to Infinity no directions kind
of a perfect plane a perfect perfectly
even table
and um
so euclidean geometry is about various
geometric figures on the plane
specifically lines triangles circles
things like that
so what's an example of an axiom an
example of an axiom is that if you have
two points
which are not which are distinct two
points on the plane then there is a
unique line which passes through them
now kind of sounds reasonable
but this is an example of an Axion
in mathematics you can you have to have
a seed so to speak you have to start
with something
and you have to choose certain
postulates or statements which you
simply take for granted which do not
require proof usually they are ones
which kind of intuitively clear to you
but in any case you cannot have you
could not have any mathematics without
choosing those actions and you refer to
those as the Observer because they're
kind of subjective The Observer comes in
the process of choosing the axons
who chooses the axons the turtles
is Ellen what's you know like to say who
is watching The Watcher yeah and so in
mathematics but you see mathematicians
are so clever
it's really kind of like a little kind
of a game of mirrors that we often like
to say and I used to say that
um that mathematics is objective it's
really one the only objective science
but that's because we hide this
this fact in the basement is based on
axioms and the fact that
that there is no there is no unique
choice
there are many choices
and so euclidean geometry is actually a
good illustration of this because
Euclid had five axioms four of them were
kind of obvious like the one I just
mentioned and the fifth
which came to be known famously as the
fifth postulate was that if you have a
line
and you have a point outside of this
line there is a unique line passing
through that point which is parallel to
the first line meaning that doesn't
intersect it
and Euclid himself was uncomfortable
about this because he felt that it was
kind of a you know the York City takes
for granted something that is not
obvious
and for me for many for many centuries
after that mathematicians were trying to
derive this action from other actions
which were more obvious in some sense
and they failed
and it was only almost 2000 years later
that Magnus realized that you can't not
only you cannot derive but you can
actually replace it with its opposite
and you will still get a bonafide
a consistent not self-contradictory
which is called non-euclidean geometry
which of course sounds very complicated
but it's not think of a sphere just the
surface of a basketball or the surface
of the Earth I know idealized
the analogues so do you have points you
have analogues of lines which have
meridians right and every two meridians
intersect
unlike parallel lines on a flat space
there is also so called hyperbolic plane
where
no the infinitely many lines which do
not intersect so every possibility can
be realized there are different flavors
this is a good illustration of what a
formal system is
you start with a set of axioms
those statements you take for granted
and this is where you have a choice
and by making different choices you
actually create different mathematics
after that there are rules of inference
logical rules such as if a is true and a
plus applies B then B is true
most of them were actually introduced
already by Aristotle
even before Euclid
and then it runs as follows
you have the axioms which are accepted
as true statements then you have a way
to produce new statements
by using the rules of logical inference
from the axioms every statement you
obtain you call ethereum
and you kind of add it to the collection
of true statements
and then the question is how far can you
go how many statements can you prove
this way
of course you want it to be the system
to be non-trivial in the sense that you
don't prove everything
because if you prove everything it would
mean that it's self-contradictory that
you'd prove a statement a and it's
negation so that's kind of useless
it has to be discriminating enough
so that it doesn't doesn't prove
contradictory statements
so that there is already a question of
that mathematical consistency it has to
be consistent in the sense that
it is not self-contradictory
and then the idea that was basically
prevalent in the world of mathematics by
the beginning of the 20th century was
that in principle all of mathematics
could be derived this way we just have
to find the correct system of axioms
and then everything you ever need
would be
um could be produced by this
procedure which is really algorithmic
procedure which which actually could be
run on a computer
now think about it what is special about
this process
in this process you are just
manipulating
symbols basically you're going from one
statement to another without really
understanding the meaning of it so it's
an ideal playground for a computer
program
it's a purely syntactic process where
there are some rules some rigid rules
of passing from one statement to the
next
most mathematician mathematicians
believed that this way you can produce
all true statements and if this were
true it would give a lot of credibility
to the thesis that everything in life is
computational
or life is computation because then at
least mathematics is computational
because then it can be programmed
and the computer after efficient time
depending on on its capacity would
produce every true statement
so gyoto's first incompleteness theorem
says that that's not the case
and it's not just says it but it proves
it at you know the highest level of
rigor that is available in math Max that
is to say within another formal system
that he was operating in
so more precisely
what he proved was that if you have a
sufficiently sophisticated formal system
that is to say that you can talk about
numbers whole numbers in it that you
have whole numbers one two three four
you you have you can you have formalized
the procedure the operation of
additional multiplication
within the system
if it is consistent that is to say if
it's not complete completely useless
then there will be a true statement in
it which cannot be derived by this
linear syntactic process of proving
theorems from axioms
it's really incredible so this was a
revolution 1931 a revolution in logic
Revolution mathematics we're still
feeling the Tremors of
of this discovery